it started with birthday presents yeah
so tommy bought me a birthday present
for uh my wife bought me a shitty one
for like my 46 birthdays yeah yeah yeah
that never changes i know your money too
she bought me a [ __ ] wallet last year
okay a wallet like yeah yeah yeah now
she picks how i put that [ __ ] in my
pocket yeah like a wallet's a very
personal opinion yeah no one buys other
people's [ __ ] wallets
name on it to me oh to me does it look
like it just says tom yeah yeah
she
[Laughter]
do you realize how many people are
putting his wife's name in their mouth
so three years ago
i got a [ __ ] birthday present i got a
generator from my wife and i was like
i was like
[ __ ] yeah and i was like she's like you
like do you like it and i was like no
and then i'm sitting in my mannequin my
daughter's gonna be [ __ ] my daughter's
got me an owl one year yeah like there's
an owl to sit in my man cave with me and
i can drink with yes i like owls and
then they took it away and that was my
birthday present yeah so tom
georgia comes right into my back my
oldest comes back and she goes don't go
out front
tommy sent you the best gift and i was
like what and then isla comes in she
goes
buns sent you the best gift dad and i
get out and it's a 3 000
electric bike that goes 40 miles an hour
oh which one it's uh i don't know huck
the big one it looks like a beach
cruiser and so and so
he calls me goes go go outside i go
outside i see it that night i get drunk
i take it everywhere i have the best
[ __ ] time and i get the next day i
see him we do two bears and i go it was
really thoughtful of you and he goes
well i enjoyed it and i thought you
would enjoy it
and we started talking about how men
know men better yeah and we theorize
that gay men give the best birthday
presents and then gay listeners started
emailing in their birthday presents
because with gay men they have to one-up
each other every year because they're
men but they also love each other so
like i got subway series tickets for my
boyfriend so tom and i like that's what
we do we're gonna do gay birthdays we're
gonna do five every year you gotta buy
someone and so i was like his birthday
is in april it's this april 15th and so
i said uh
i got him last year i got him a a
fifteen thousand dollar jet ski so he
moved to austin that goes 70 miles per
hour on the water and he calls me up
he's like i love it and then this year i
was really busy and he spent seventy
thousand dollars on me for my birthday
he flew me in private jets the g5s from
minneapolis into austin from austin to
sugarland from sugarland to la from la
back out he put me up at the four
seasons everywhere yeah and he was like
that's your birthday present so i just
spent a hundred thousand dollars on his
birthday this year he spent a lot more
than seventy thousand on those jets
i think he did and a lot more i i bought
him a race team
bought him a race team two bears racing
so we've already sold ad sales to
sponsors on the outside of the car we're
gonna do endurance racing matt farah
from the smoking tire kind of hooked
everything up yeah i bought him a bmw
we're getting it wrapped it just got
delivered to austin the we have i bought
a trailer i got a smoker i got four more
tires i got three flame retardant suits
i think rogan's gonna run in our first
race but it's endurance racing and so we
i i have the whole [ __ ] inside of the
car pimped out with electronics so you
can live stream from the car during a
[ __ ] race it is [ __ ] badass so
yeah we started two bears racing and the
endurance racing is like it's a 24 i
don't really know what the [ __ ] it is
that's what i'm the money man behind me
okay he looks like an endurance athlete
right like
the guy with the cigar going god damn it
he's running those tires hot yeah like
that's me that's my partner
so yeah it just got delivered wow that's
a good good good good good good good
cocktail yeah i think that's a great
idea does tom know about this yeah well
yes yeah it got complicated we need to
get his sizes we had to start an llc i
mean it's like [ __ ] it's
being an adult
guys thank you so much for watching that
clip from the flagrant two podcast and i
just need to let you know it is march
madness and the national championship is
up for grabs and so is the bag with my
bookie sign up today at my bookie and
use the promo code flagrant to secure a
first deposit bonus up to 1 000 it's
simple deposit 200 and play with 300
instantly just use the promo code
flagrant to claim your bonus mobile or
on the go college or nba no matter the
league no matter the minute my bookie
puts the action in your hands so you can
turn any game day into a payday bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
you